in a world with
one man versus his own mind
and 24 hours this
is a game jam there's
just one problem
his game asteroids totally different
this time
is actually not different
man it's just asteroids
that's kind of a problem uh i can't even
shoot that's even worse
oh my gosh okay
uh it's not different at all i mean it
uses all this cool stuff
type to raise physics i had all this fun
making it
but the players don't care about that at
all what am i gonna do
there are only a few hours left before
the deadline
maybe i can like quickly change it
maybe all right what can i do here all
right um
okay i could try like maybe making the
ship huge like all right i'll
try that just make the ship huge
okay all right i got a big ship
cool uh yeah it's the same game
that's that's really a problem okay
asteroids tiny
that'll be hard to hit that'll be fun
people like hard games right
right thank you
oops uh
okay well now it's just this is just bad
so that's that's just no good that's no
good at all um
okay what the heck am i gonna do
like oh
what if you
control the asteroids
yes i could do this this is something i
could do this is something that would
win
i would this is awesome okay yes yes yes
awesome totally cool
let's do this oh
wait wait how will i have the time this
is not an easy thing to do i'm totally
changing my game
how is this gonna how's this gonna be
possible
oh right yeah that's right i modeled
everything as data
okay that's awesome yeah right right
okay cool uh all right what does that
mean i totally i've oh
crap i forgot okay
uh is that like a database or something
because databases are pretty fun right
no no they're not they're really boring
actually they're
really quite boring and also not a game
you know like
in fact if you like go up to one and hit
the action button a few times you can
kind of like
capture one and eventually you know but
then it corrupts your saved game and you
really kind of get screwed over because
then your game is gone
so my god i've devolved into meme i'm oh
sorry sorry i'm back back
totally back okay all right all right so
what what are we talking about here okay
well before we discover what we're
talking about let's talk about how
another version of asteroids might have
been created
okay one that uses object an object
oriented approach
as opposed to this mystical data concept
um so with an object-oriented approach
you'd have
your asteroid your ship you have your
bullet
you'd have maybe some other things they
would inherit from each other
that might look like this on the left is
an asteroid and the right is a bullet
they're very similar they all inherit
from
a renderable thing which inherits from a
collidable thing because things have to
adam smash which renders from a physics
entity which renders fro
or inherits from like a global world
thing great
the ship is a bit more interesting the
ship might actually inherit from
uh keyboard control because we don't
need to move it around right
and there's going to be a lot of
implementations done
in each of these areas of the hierarchy
especially the ship itself right
we might have an update and if anyone
saw hunter's talk in the other room he
was talking about update functions
you're going to have that kind of
throughout your hierarchy
you're going to have concrete
implementations of things such as
draw it's actually going to be in the
ship even though something's renderable
it needs to know how to render itself
and you know shoot of course is going to
be in the ship as well because the ship
shoots
great so if we wanted to refactor our
code
because this is great code right you can
totally tell what's going on here
if we wanted to refactor this fake code
to enable controllable asteroids what
would that look like well
maybe this we'd have to physically take
our inheritance tree
on the left there we have to take the
keyboard controlled entity
rip it out and put it into our asteroid
entity
as well as just physically copy code
like the handle input
handling like keyboard and stuff and the
shoot function
probably a bunch of other things too
probably have to handle copying over
data properties
and it's pretty hard to know what those
are but they'd all have to be copied or
pasted over into the asteroid
that'd be kind of tricky and of course
keep in mind the real world is
definitely
a bit worse um you know this is a game
jam right
you just write code and get it done and
that is really
messy code so it would be worse
so pros and cons real quick
you get kind of faked out all of your
logic is local it like appears to be
local you know all of your logic is in
the ship
or in the renderable or in the
collidable but really it's spread out
throughout the entire
hierarchy as well as the state your
position
rotation shapes images things like that
are all spread throughout this
large object hierarchy and it's kind of
hard to reason about
it's also hard to optimize since you
have to deal with these
fat objects which may have different
interfaces
and you don't know it's hard to do that
so um
you are restricted from making certain
types of optimizations
so that's the object-oriented approach
the data-oriented approach
which is what my asteroids game is
actually made out of
has three main tenants the first is that
functions operate on data
not capital o objects and what i mean by
this
are because obviously new object is
capital o it's valid syntax okay okay
okay
but what i mean by this is that uh
an object meaning a fat object something
that is
inherited sorry inherits from many other
objects or has
methods attached to it anything more
than just simple data
so we want functions that are relatively
pure there's always going to be more
than one
of the data that you're operating on
there's always going to be more than one
canvas
even though it's a game in the browser
there probably is going to be more than
one for double buffering or
or like effects or something there could
even be more than one ship
there could be more than one asteroid of
course there's more than one asteroid
and the final tenant is to not inhibit
optimization
if the developer chooses to do that
and we'll see how in a little bit mostly
that means batching things up
so this is not perfect i barely know
what i'm talking about
let's move on so it all starts with a
pocket
and this system um this thing that i
wrote
i i wrote it obviously but i didn't
write it to be a library that you all
use
i wrote it to demonstrate these ideas um
so
just keep that in mind so it starts with
a pocket and a pocket is just a
container just like
your pocket um
and it also has a tick method meaning
that every time
uh you want to update the pocket or
maybe call something you're going to
call this tick method
it's not really important but just so
you know that it's something that's
constantly running
once we have a pocket then we can add
component types
to the pocket you mean like like in
react
you know maybe well no
no not not at all actually um
components in react are they uh they
don't have a ton of state but they do
have a little bit of state or they can
have state and they also have methods
or like functions inside of them so
these are a little bit different here's
an example of one
this is a rotation component type it's
the definition
of what rotation means
in terms of of data in terms of
properties
it has an angle property and a rate
property and they both default to zero
and if we look uh the pocket when when
it's uh
when it's told to create one of these is
going to pass in an object the cmp
object
that we then use to attach our
properties to so this is a
pattern implying you pass in options and
then you get back
you get back some data there's also on
on the further slides the shortcut
which is cmp type just to save typing
you know but it stands for component
type so in further slides you'll see
that instead
here's another example of a drag
component meaning
something that slows down over time it's
being dragged upon by an external force
there's no functionality here there's
just the data required to implement drag
which is
a percentage of velocity kept each frame
or each time we call update we'll see
how it works in a minute but
just notice it's just data these are
just kind of plain objects
once we have our component types
our definitions once we have once we
have that we can then request a key
from our pocket because your pocket
always has keys right
now a key is uh simply a collection
of component types that will be turned
into instances of that component
so in this case we're requesting a key
be made that points at
rotation and drag and we're passing in a
default value of rate
0.9 to the rotation this is important
because i said earlier it defaults to
zero so we're overriding that value
the key that we get back is just an id
and it is a number
it is simply used to index into
something else
um this is important later i swear
but it's just an id here's a bigger
example i know the code it's a lot of
code
it's not important to notice all the
details here it's only important to
notice that there are several
different things in quotes those are the
component types and then the thing after
it are the
options passed into each component so in
this case
there's no options passed into thrust or
drag but rotation has it has a default
value
default rate so this is actually ship
this is how the ship
is defined in the asteroids game
we define our points and some other
things which i'll get into more
so once we have our component data and
our keys
then we can write systems and these are
going to modify
our component data and here's how that
looks like
this is the system or effectively the
functionality
required to apply thrust to
to something in the game so first of all
it has a name it has
requirements these are the types of data
that it operates on and this
system will only be invoked if those
types of datas
exist and finally
what the system does is its action the
system is invoked
it's given a list of keys that have all
these different components
and then finally also given collections
of each component that you can index
into
and this is what that looks like you can
see
var k equals keys we're looping through
each key using it to index into the
collection of positions
shapes and rotations now the actual code
that
does like in this case render point
shape in the previous slide was uh
was apply thrust that code is not on
these slides just so you know it's not
like a magical oh and suddenly it moves
um this is just showing the structure
around it because that stuff's pretty
much the same in most games
okay here's another example
of a system or i'm sorry here is the uh
the input thrust system but
there's one more little shortcut that
i'm going to be using on further slides
and that is that rather than in previous
in this previous slide
the system is invoked once and then loop
through you loop through each key
manually
in this case uh the system is invoked
once for each key
and it gives you the data that you want
your position rotation thrust
it's just a shortcut don't worry too
much about it
but i just wanted to point that out
okay now at the beginning of this we
talked about player controlled asteroids
right okay so are we ever going to come
back to that we've been
it's like talking for a while now
all right so yes the first step is
rotation we want to take our uh our
asteroids and make them rotatable
because the ship can rotate around
that's the first step to moving around
so here's the rotation code this is it
this is all the code responsible for
rotating
something um
it has a rotation component and a human
controlled 0 1 component how scientific
sounding
and you might be wondering well what's
up with that and also why
is there no data being passed in called
human control zero one
and the question or the answer is uh
there isn't one and this is our last
components or sorry our last part of
our pocket system and those that is that
we use labels
as anonymous components these are just
ways to
label a key as something
this is the definition of an asteroid it
has a position
a shape a bounding box and a rotation it
also has an asteroid
it has itself it just has a name it just
has a name of asteroid
and this is useful because for example
in the asteroid ship collider code
we only want to talk to asteroids we
only want to deal with the asteroids
and a ship is very similar to an
asteroid actually the ship
also has shape position and rotation so
our asteroid tag or label is the only
thing that makes
this system only be invoked for
asteroids instead of
all of these things and just
the pocket gives you a little warning i
don't think you can even see that but
if it if it doesn't find the component
just says hey i didn't find it
i'm assuming it's a label i hope it's
what you meant
okay so now back to this rotation this
is our first
step in making the asteroids
controllable
we add we have this tag called
humancontrol01 or this label
what happens if we just add it to the
asteroids maybe something awesome
let's find out use our asteroid
down here can everyone yes perfect all
right
i will add this in
save it refresh hey
that's not working at all what happened
what happened well what happened is that
um we have our human control zero one
that's great
what didn't happen is that if we look at
the system itself
it accepts a rotation and it uses the
rate
to increase the angle of rotation
the logic here is not that important
what is important is that this component
rotation has a default value of zero for
the rate
so on our asteroid we need to make sure
that instead of just using the defaults
we use
an actual value so here's what that
looks like
here's our rotation
save refresh we've got asteroids moving
around
i swear they're moving around but hold
on a sec let me
undo my changes from before those are
really boring changes
asteroids are moving all right all right
cool
so there's step one okay
yes now let's make them thrust
so to make them thrust here's our
thrusting code
uh we look at its requirements it has a
position rotation thrust and human
control zero one
we already have human control zero one
looks like all we need is thrust
so here's what thrust looks like in the
ship
let's add it to the asteroid
here's our asteroid over here
and refresh okay we're spinning we're
spinning and we're moving
okay yes we have a a cloud of asteroids
okay we're really getting somewhere now
let's make them shoot
okay so if we look at the the asteroid
all we need to do is add this projectile
launcher uh
thing which is um it's already on the
ship so let's just add this into the
asteroid
this will be this should be pretty good
let's see projectile
launcher and the value was launch force
that's how much that's like how much
power it how fast it goes
hit refresh oh yeah look at that
they're just i've got i've got so many
asteroids just shooting now
and they even kill themselves look oh i
can't
there we go yeah just killing themselves
um
it's not even a challenge anymore for
the ship he's just like yeah
all right that's cool but now let's make
the ship get hit right
let's let's reverse things here so uh
this is the code that is responsible
i mean minus the actual code but this is
the system that's responsible for
colliding asteroids and the projectiles
okay
the only thing that is specific to
asteroids about this system aside from
the name
which doesn't really mean anything it's
just a some string
is the asteroid label and remember that
we just added that asteroid label to the
to the asteroid for the heck of it so
that we could do things like this
so what happens if we take this system
and instead of telling it to operate on
asteroids
we tell it to operate on ships okay
let's try that so here's our projectile
collider
i'm gonna change this to ship keep in
mind if we go back to ship real quick
it has a ship tag or a label
hit refresh and
now if we chase there we go it killed
itself
but if we chase the ship eventually
where'd it go eventually if it hits
if it hits okay
i should have made the ship bigger so
you can see that the bullets are not
being hit by the projectiles anymore
or the the asteroids but the ship
yeah oh go get it
okay trust me it it it dies
oh
okay all right all right i'm gonna do it
for real now all right here we go
wait wait here we go for real okay it
will be impossible to miss right
ah okay got it
okay the hunter has become the hunted
now the asteroids finally have their
revenge
okay and there's still tons more work to
do tons more to do
uh but but not today because there's
just limited time in this talk
you know we could we could finish up
this this uh this thing
so talking about the data oriented
approach
um and some pros and cons these are kind
of the same thing i call them pro
cons because they're sometimes they're
beneficial sometimes they're not
one logic is spread out you have many
systems
your logic is in each system and it can
be uh it can be kind of tricky
to have them all spread out because it's
all these separate systems but it's also
kind of nice because they are separated
your state is completely consolidated
you have components
that the systems operate upon and the
state the only thing that changes are
those components
because we cannot we can create a system
uh that operates on a whole range of
components it's a little bit easier to
optimize if we wanted to make all of our
positions backed by a typed array
for fast integer math we could do that
because all of our
um all of our positions are actually
stored in the same same kind of area
same same data and as you just saw it's
extremely modular
we could take labels we could take code
and just kind of move them around and
get totally different functionality
well pretty different functionality so
i did mention databases quite a long
time ago
so what what what does that mean well
there's actually a pretty good
one-to-one analog between what i've done
here
and the concepts of a database or at
least at a at a
you know fuzzy level let's just say so
our component types
our definitions are roughly equivalent
to tables
it's like a schema we define a table
each property is a column
in that table such as our position has a
our rotation has a rate
and angle those are just like columns in
a table
our components are like the individual
entries
in the table they're the rows you know
each individual instance of rotation
is just a row in the rotation table our
keys are primary keys
that's why they're called key also the i
mean the pocket come on let's see that
ended up being pretty good i think
and then uh finally our systems are like
stored no they're not like store
procedures at all
uh they're more like queries and
business logic kind of
mixed together which is like php land or
something but
it's okay because it's it's game
development it's fine
all right and just to show you how much
like a database this really is um if we
take here's our pocket
our pocket instance our container of
things if we look at all the different
components in it and just
log that out just stringify and log it
out we get this
it gets interesting if we kind of scroll
down to
the positions this is the position for
key number four you know this is like
entity number four or thing number four
our values are right there this was a
snapshot in time
at when this when this snapshot was
taken when we stringified this
um the x and y values were 719 and 397.
so it's like an instant
save state almost and with just a little
bit of tweaking you could actually have
saved states with this it's not not
too hard another example is uh rotation
here's the rotation for
key number four it didn't actually have
an angle set but it did have a rate
yay okay cool
i'm sure you're all wondering did i
actually finish the game jam
right that was that's probably the
number one question on your minds
right now and get ready
i hope you're prepared i didn't
um there wasn't even a jam
it was just for this talk i'm sorry if i
confused anyone
i'm sorry if you feel gypped but that's
that's all it was there was no game jam
and uh you know i hope that's okay
thank you very much